I'm worried I I think wokism is an issue
but I also think these arguments are
distraction from what's happened on the
economic side of things yeah we have we
are trapped between inflation and high
taxation and then people are struggling
well I agree with you I I don't think of
those things as being uh separate or
even counter to each other if you think
about what you said about inflation
being right wing that is a symptom of
what I'm talking about which is we have
dumb conversations instead of addressing
real issues and to me that is the core
of wokeness actually I mean if you think
about some of the key principles behind
that ideology one of them is uh the
instead of looking at people in terms of
the circumstances into which they're
born and in which they grow up this used
to be kind of how they left used to look
at things you know if you're born into a
working class family your outcomes in
life are less likely to be as good as
someone who grows up in an affluent area
in an affluent family right
um that used to be the way we saw so and
so if you didn't used to matter whether
you were black or white or whatever it
was more about you know are you poor
basically right and if you are poor
that's who we should be targeting things
at now we've created this very perverse
system where you know you've got Elite
people from Minority backgrounds being
given opportunities and rewarded not for
their skills and talents and Merit but
for the fact that they Sim they look
like some people who had a bad lot in
life sometime in the past or even do
today and so very often some of the
guests we've had on the show will talk
about how
this is really unhelpful to working
class minority people because what's
happening is in order to pretend that
we're helping them we're helping some
Elite people who also have dark skin
right and that to me is is a big problem
now in terms of economics uh I mean I I
understand what you're saying and I
agree with it and I've been you know
what one of the reasons that I think
people underestimate the importance of
the economic issues is the housing
crisis we have in this country and I
always say to my conservative friends
how do you expect people to have a more
conservative-minded frame of the World
when they literally have no attachment
and no grounding in the place in which
they live where they're living with five
people in in a flat in London they can't
partner up they can't marry they can't
have kids and these are all the things
that are gonna put you into the real
world in a way that you and I both as
parents know like once you've got kids
you sort of start to see the world in a
very different way right well if you've
got people in the mid and late 30s who
physically cannot have kids what do you
what you think they're going to be
conservative you think they're going to
have that pragmatic approach and it's
not going to happen right so I agree
with you the economics is important but
I also think we shouldn't underestimate
the nature of the threat to our society
from some of the stuff that's being
pushed by this ideology and I'll give
you a couple of examples I mean one of
them is the diversity bureaucracy right
if you think about what that is that is
essentially a system of anti-meritocracy
right now if you run a business which
you and I both do and you operate that
business by employing people not because
of how good they are at their job
but by what boxes they tick what is
likely to be the economic outcome of
that sort of approach that's negative
negative now look at government not
Optimum not optimal right look at
government look at education look at any
system in which this is heavily
practiced this way of looking at the
world is anti-meritocratic is therefore
anti-results it's therefore putting us
at a disadvantage against other people
and other competitor countries so you
can see how it starts to affect
everything uh and so to me these things
are not disconnected because this way of
looking at the world prevents us from
accurately responding to the very real
challenges that you're talking about do
you think the primary issue then is that
we've elevated people essentially stupid
people who don't think rationally about
situations into positions of power who
are able to Rally troops around them
with slogans and virtues a bit like the
the just stop oil people the way I'm
somebody who cares about the environment
and also fully understand that their
argument is completely stupid I mean
just just the point just stop oil
doesn't make any sense at all no so is
it this elevation of
it's almost like there isn't a
meritocracy to the elevation
of power absolutely and I think
um you know I'm wary of saying that it's
stupid people at the top because the
more you meet them you realize they're
not stupid uh my view is that most of
them aren't anyway my view is that
people respond to incentives right and
if you create a perverse incentive
structure
then you end up with perverse outcomes
and I think that is much more the
situation that we've got and just stop
oil is a very good example of this like
you I think the environment is really
important I don't think we're going to
fix climate change to the extent that it
needs fixing uh by making billions of
people poor I don't think we're gonna
fix it by you know for freezing
pensioners to death and Britain every
winter because we don't have enough
energy uh you know I think we have to
have a pragmatic approach to all of
these problems if we're going to fix
them and so if you create an environment
where shouting about how much of a
victim you are gets you attention and is
rewarded with TV time and I end up
debating these people on on various
shows all the time and stuff like that
they they're there not because of Mary
but because they're making a lot of
noise and therefore the issues that
actually ought to be dealt with aren't
getting dealt with in a rational way how
have we got here from from your kind of
yeah understanding the background to
this has this been just an organic
movement or is there something more
Sinister going on is this yeah how do we
get how did we get here yes because I
don't know it's all those things in some
ways so one of the things I think is
social media